we've got some breaking news in the
trial of Lucy letby she is the neonatal
nurse who is accused of killing seven
babies while she was working in the
neonatal unit at the Countess of Chester
Hospital well we know that 32 year old
is accused of attempting to murder 10
babies within the same period between
June 2015 and June 2016. the court has
now been shown what they're saying is a
handwritten confession allegedly written
by letby on Post-it notes in her home
which said I am evil I did this a series
of notes and Post-it notes were found
during a search of her home on one green
Post-It note which was shown to the
court
she apparently wrote I don't deserve to
live I killed him on purpose because I'm
not good enough
she also apparently wrote I am a
horrible evil person
and in capital letters said I am evil I
did this
well let me denies all of the charges
over the incidents at the Countess of
Chester Hospital but the prosecution has
presented a great deal of evidence over
the last couple of days just opening the
case at the Crown Court also the court
was told today that there were photos
seen on Lucy Levy's phone that she took
photos of two of the dead children in
their cots after they had died so it has
been once again a day of really
distressing evidence in the court this
morning let's go to our correspondent
Greg mylam who joins us from Manchester
Crown Court Greg these hand written
notes do seem to be quite a striking
piece of evidence
will the prosecution uh Casey Nick
Johnson has been finishing that opening
statement the fourth day of his opening
statement to the jury and the last part
was that detail of what happened after
Lucy letby had been arrested and when
the police searched her home uh in
Chester and they described finding those
those Post-it notes full of closely
written uh words they say on them names
of some of her colleagues questions
about why this has happened the
allegations against her the process some
protestations of Innocence Mr Johnson
said I haven't done anything wrong she
said they've got no evidence against me
continuing to protest her innocence but
then he showed the one he showed to the
jury was that that Post-It note uh with
it with a lot of text on it I've got to
say but in in the middle of that post in
that note those lines you just mentioned
I don't deserve to live I kill them all
on purpose because I'm not good enough
to care for them uh Mr Johnson said I'm
a horrible evil person I am evil I did
this but as Mr Johnson pointed out it is
for the jury to decide on on the facts
in this case based on the evidence and
he's laid out a lot of the allegations
and a little earlier in the day he'd
finished talking about the the children
She's accused of either murdering or
attempting uh to murder as he has done
over the last few days and talked about
child p as we have to identify that
child one of triplets and She's accused
of killing two of those triplets
and a similar pattern he described where
under Lucy letby's care that child
suffered a serious deterioration in his
condition was fine and recovered well
under the care of other nurses and when
one of those children was being child P
was being transferred to another
hospital for more intensive care one of
the doctors who was there said to
remembers that Lucy let me said to him
uh he's not leaving here alive is he and
that phrase surprised the doctor Mr
Johnson said but as Mr Johnson said that
came true because she knew what she had
done to him it was likely to happen
because she intended it to happen and
she'd done it to so many children Mr
Johnson said in that case as with so
many it was her malign hand at work the
court is now broken we will then hear
the opening statement from the defense
for Lucy letby she denies all 22 charges
against her